This is the nucleus of the galaxy M87 and this is the first ever image of a black hole.
(applause)
When I saw the first image I said, you know, wow, that's it.
It's a true, like a Eureka moment, in our scientific lives.
We're looking at this... the mystery of nature that has never... uncovered, right, so... (laughs)
So this is it. We've finally seen it.
Scientists came up with this crazy idea in the 1930s
and they never imagined that one day we would actually see a black hole.
It's so far only a few blurry splotches of light
and yet they contain so much information
about the physics of the universe.
I've been dreaming about this for 25 years.
When I saw the first data it was just some weird plot
and it looked like there could be a ring in there.
I was like oh my god, this is gonna be interesting.
It looks pretty much what we were
expecting which was for a theoretician
is always an, you know, a dramatic moment
when you have to compare what you spent
years simulating with what actually
nature is telling you.
This is just like kind of the beginning of being able to have another window
into what black holes can tell us about our laws and, and physics...
um, but already we've learned so much, so you know, we didn't know,
even though we had predicted that if you had
a black hole that you would see this
ring of light, we didn't know we were
gonna get that ring of light. And that's you
know what we were kind of testing.
We could have gotten just a blob. And so
seeing that ring and seeing a ring that
has a size that is consistent with other
measurements that had been done
completely differently... I think that in
itself just being able to see that ring
of light, being able to see that that ring
exists, is huge.
We are also releasing this data that has, from the event
horizon telescope that were used to
create this image, so whoever out there
has a you know alternative theory of
gravity can just grab this data and test it.
Well the big goal still is to make an image of the black hole in the centre  of our Milky Way,
because it has a much better determined mass
and so we can do
much better tests of general relativity.
And we can also have other telescopes
look at it.
There are near-infrared interferometers which see gas going around it
so combining all this information will give us a much better image of how black holes actually work.
The picture we have seen today is only a first taste of what the Event Horizon Telescope can deliver.
Already the data they have in the bag can produce a lot more information,
for example about what produces the jets,
these enormous beams of light that we see coming out of the galaxy M87.
Also the team has collected a lot of data about another black hole,
the one at the center of our own galaxy.
And they haven't even started analyzing that, so stay tuned there's a lot more to come
you